deux remarques la première c'est que sur
un sujet aussi important
alors que hier c'était le jour où le
président de la république a promulgué
la loi quand elle n'est pas débattue au
parlement et quelque chose d'assez
surprenant du point de vue du
fonctionnement de notre démocratie puis
la deuxième remarque c'est que au fond
cette histoire n'était qu'un prétexte
pour faire une allocution de près de 20
minutes sans aucun contradicteur qui est
un acte de campagne moi je me fais une
très haute idée de la fonction
présidentielle
par ailleurs j'ai plutôt la réputation
d'être un modéré et soucieux d'
équilibre qu un polémiste ou un orage et
je vais vous dire que j'ai trouvé cette
allocution parfaitement incongru entre
le président de la république s'exprime
c'est qu'il a une décision importante
pour l'avenir de la nation selon vous ce
n'est pas une décision rien ou bien
parce que il y à un événement
international ou national qui le
justifie quand il ya eu des attentats
terroristes par exemple quand il ya eu
pour jacques chirac la guerre en irak ça
ça justifie que toutes affaires
cessantes
le président s'exprime mais pas à cinq
mois d'une élection présidentielle pour
vanter un bilan et énoncer un projet qui
regroupe à peu près tout ce qu'il n'a
pas fait pendant son quinquennat et
cette phrase en fin d'allocution qui a
consisté à dire nous avons réussi
l'impensable et d'une d'un culot tout à
fait stupéfiant je crois que ont fait
mieux d'être modeste quand on a été
obligé peut-être mais comme on aggrave
encore les choses d'augmenter de 20% la
dette publique elle est passée à 120% du
pib il faudra bien la payer cette dette
publique et raconter qu'on à la
croissance la plus phénoménale
le tout le monde et de l'europe en
particulier quand on a eu la récession
la plus phénoménale l'année précédente
c'est tout simplement essayé de faire
une propagande de nature électorale et
donc vous le sentez j'ai été en réalité
assez choqué de cette intervention et je
trouve que si le président de la
république veut faire acte de campagne
il doit déclarer sa candidature et ne
pas se servir de la fonction
présidentielle au service de sa campagne
merci philippe bas merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
[Musique]